ja ich begrüße alle teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer des existenz seminars zu
aktuellen sitzung in der es um gottlob
frege geht aber wie immer werde ich
bevor wir näher darauf eingehen noch
rückblick geben nämlich eine
zusammenfassung geben von der letzten
sitzung und da hatten wir martin
heidegger behandelt und ein ausschnitt
diskutiert aus seinem werk sein und zeit
sein und zeit ist das hauptwerk von
martin heidegger und es ist natürlich
sehr kompliziert sehr komplex wir haben
uns nur die passage ausgesucht die für
unser seminar von interesse ist nämlich
die passage wo er über existenz spricht
wir hatten verschiedene leitfragen also
inwiefern unterscheidet heiliger
zwischen kategorien und existenziellen
kategorien hatten sie schon in der
sitzung über aristoteles mitbekommen da
mache ich oben rechts ein link zu der
jeweiligen sitzung dann eine weitere
frage ist welche neurologischen status
hat das dasein
dann spricht heiliger davon wie
verhalten sich existenz und essenzen
blick auf das dasein wie verhält sich
heiligers existenz lehre zu den bisher
behandelten theorie natürlich vor allem
aristoteles das sind so die fragen und
jetzt möchte ich mitten im text hinein
gehen und ein paar ganz wichtige zitate
ihn nochmal präsentieren und kurz
analysieren er sagt folgendes dass seine
dessen analyse zur aufgabe steht in
diesem werk seiner zeit sind wir je
selbst dass sein dieses seinem ist je
meines ihm sein dieses seinen verhält
sich dieses selbst zu seinem sein als
sein dass dieses science ist ist seinen
eigenen seien über antwort dass sein ist
es darum es diesem sein denn je zeigt
geht das ist das dasein das dasein ist
dass sein dem es in seinem sein um zeit
sein geht jetzt kann man da sagen das
ist der mensch natürlich der mensch
macht sich auch gedanken wie man sein
sein aber wie wir am ende dieser
versehen werden möchte heiliger nicht an
der anthropologie betreiben als er
möchte ganz bewusst für diese
existenzform die ihr hier analysiert den
begriff des daseins wählen und nicht
denen des menschen
und jetzt kommt er auf das wesen zu
sprechen sie haben ja sich noch erinnert
wir hatten verschiedene sitzungen ich
mach oben rechts wieder im link rhein
unter anderem zu thomas von aquin und da
ging es immer um das verhältnis von
essential also verwiesen und fang
existenziell und beide hatte thomas von
aquin voneinander getrennt und wir
schauen jetzt mal wie heiliger das
verhältnis von essens- und existenz
bestimmt also heiliger sagt das wesen
dieses sein denn liegt in seinem zu sein
also dieses seine damit ist jetzt das
dasein gemacht das war sein
die essenz dieses seinen muss sofern
überhaupt davon gesprochen werden kann
aus seinem seiner existenz begriffen
werden dabei ist es gerade die
ontologische aufgabe zu zeigen dass wenn
wir für das sein dieses seinen die
bezeichnung existenz wäre dieser titel
nicht die unter logische bedeutung des
überlieferten terminus existenziell hat
und haben kann existenz habe sagt unter
logisch so viel wie vorhandensein eines
science art die dem sein denn vom
charakter des daseins wesens mäßig nicht
zu kommen
eine verwirrung wird dadurch vermieden
dass wir für den titel existenz ja immer
dem interpretierenden ausdruck vorhanden
haid gebrauchen und existenz als seins
bestimmung allein dem dasein zu weisen
also heiliger unterscheidet existenz von
loser vorhanden haid und reserviert die
bedeutung von existenz nur für das
dasein
also wird das sein dem es mit seinem
sein um sein sein geht während vorhanden
das bezeichnet was die gängige tradition
bisher unter existenz verstand also was
es alles gibt zum beispiel eine tasse
das wäre bloße vorhanden haid oder ein
smartphone aber existenz kommt nur uns
zu insofern es uns um unser sein geht
heiliger hat dann ganz verschiedene
formen der science verhältnisse die man
durchaus auch als existenzialistisch
bezeichnen kann nämlich so etwas wie
angst so was wie sorge das sind alles
weisen des daseins in seiner existenz
eine tasse kann sich nicht sorgen um
etwas also wirklich im sinne des
existenzialistischen so bestimmt
heiliger dass das eine die so weiter ich
habe noch ein zentrales zitat das wesen
des daseins liegt in seiner existenz die
an diesen seien dann herausstellt barren
charaktere sind daher nicht vorhandene
eigenschaften eine so und so aussehen
den vorhandenen zeiten sondern jede
mögliche weise zu sein und nur dass
alles so sein dieses sein denn ist
primär zeit
daher rückt rückt der titel da sein mit
dem wir dieses seien die bezeichnung
nicht sein was aus wie tisch hausbaum
sonders sein also hier sind wir schon
dass heiliger das dasein nicht im sinne
von eigenschaften bestimmt oder auch wie
wir im nächsten tal ziehen werden im
sinne von kategorien
das betrifft alles nur die vorhanden
haid also zum beispiel oder auch die zu
handen haid so wird er diese person
entscheiden sie ihr löst sich schon die
note also so was wie ein großer stein
wäre etwas vorhanden ist und eine tasse
wäre sogar noch etwas besseres oder
sinnvoller es nämlich 1 zu handen seien
einzuhalten sein heißt etwas was ein
zweck hat also aus der tasse kann ich
aber vorhanden haid und zu händen halten
müssen immer noch vom dasein
unterscheiden wird weil und es werden
wir gleich sehen diese existenzform
verschieden ist das seien darum es
diesem sein denn die dasein in seinem
sein geht ist jemand da sein ist daher
nie unter logisch zu fassen als fall und
exemplar seiner gattung von sein dem als
vorhandenen diesem seinen ist sein sein
gleichgültig genau besehen es ist so
dass ihm sein seien wieder gleichgültig
noch um gleichgültig sein kann
das ansprechen von da sein muss gemäss
dem charakter der ihm einig kite dieses
zeiten stets das personalpronomen
bezahlt ich bin du bist also wir haben
eine weitere wichtige kategorie oder
genauer gesagt eine existenzielle
nämlich die jeweilig kite also das
dasein ist dadurch ausgezeichnet dass es
ihm immer um es selbst geht dieses um es
selbst gehen nennt heiliger mit einem
neuen begriffen am neologismus jeweilig
kite also heiliger versucht neue
kategorien zu entwickeln die uns als
ängstlichen besorgten wesen ihr
spezifikum verleiht und uns
unterscheidet von losen gegenständen der
welt die sich selbst nicht auf sich
selbst ängstigen oder sorgend beziehen
weiter sagt er da sein ist meines
wiederum je in dieser oder jener weise
zu sagen es hat sich schon immer
irgendwie entschieden in welcher weise
dasein je meines ist dass seine der
müssen sie sein um dieses selbst geht
verhält sich zu seinem sein als seine
eigene möglichkeit dasein ist je seine
möglichkeit und es hat sie nicht nur
noch eigenschaft lich als ein vorhanden
ist und weil das anwesen haft je seine
möglichkeit ist kann dieses sein der in
seinem sein sich selbst wählen gewinnen
es kann sich verlieren bzw
nie und nur scheinbar gewinn verloren
haben kann
nur und noch nicht sich gewonnen haben
kann es nur sofern es seinem wesen nach
mögliches eigentliches das heißt sich zu
eigen ist auch hier wieder gilt dass das
dasein ein ganz spezifisches sein das
ist nämlich eines was möglichkeiten zu
sein hat also es ist sogar seine
möglichkeit zu sein ist hat sie nicht
nur als eigenschaften sondern wir als
dasein bestehen sind in unseren
möglichkeiten und was heißt
möglichkeiten möglichkeiten sind immer
unsere freiheit als wir können uns so
oder so entwerfen
wir können auch im entwurf scheitern
wir sind aber immer noch ein da sind
auch dann wenn wir scheitern was heißt
scheitern wenn wir zum beispiel wie
heutige sagt uns fehlen also wenn wir
unseren eigenen ansprüchen ziel nicht
gerecht werden dann sind wir nicht
weniger da sein sondern gerade darin
zeigen auch dass wir da sein sind die
beiden skizzierten guard tyrese
charaktere des daseins einmal der
vorrang der existenz ja vor der essenz
ja und die einigkeit zeigen schon an
dass eine analytik dieses sein denn vor
einem eigenartigen phänomenalen bezirk
gestellt wird dieses sein hat nicht und
nie die science partners innerhalb der
welt nur vorhanden wie ein stein und so
was ein großer gegenstand
daher ist es auch nicht in der weise des
vor findens von vorhandenem thematisch
vorzugeben
die rechte vorgabe ist so wenig
selbstverständlich dass deren bestimmung
selbst ein wesentliches stück der
theologischen analytik des sein denn
ausmachen und das führt jetzt dazu dass
heiliger davon spricht dass wir nicht
vom dasein mit den bisherigen kategorien
reden dürfen die wir unter anderem bei
aristoteles kennengelernt hatten er sagt
alle exponate die der analytik des
daseins entspringen sind gewonnen im
hinblick auf seine existenz strukturen
weil sie sich aus sein aus der
existenzialist bestimmen nennen wir die
science
charaktere des daseins existenzielle sie
sind scharf getrennt von den science
bestimmung des nicht da seins mäßigen
seinen die wir kategorien
dabei wird dieser ausdruck in seiner
premieren und theologischen bedeutung
aufgenommen und festgehalten
die antike mythologie hat zum
exemplarischen wurde ihres seins
auslegung dass innerhalb der welt
begegnete sein
das können sie ganz einfach daran sehen
dass die erste kategorie in aristoteles
kategorien schrift die substanz ist und
heiliger wendet sich gegen eine
bestimmung des daseins als substanz
warum substanz scheint zumindest
nahezulegen dass es da etwas gibt was
beständig ist was fest abgeschottet ist
abgeschlossen ist von anderen substanzen
was seinem wesen nach fest konturiert
ist was determiniert ist und das möchte
heiliger mit bezug auf das dasein gerade
nicht also verhaltener ist das dasein
total flexibel und immer im entwurf
begriffen also dass da ist ein komplett
zum stillstand ist erstaunlich wie eine
substanz sollte wie ein gegenstand ein
plus vorhandenes das dann objektiv
klassifiziert werden kann sondern es
bezieht sich immer auf sich aber auch
immer auf die welt der es existiert und
heutigen diesel dieses existenzielle
diese struktur auch das in der welt sein
und dieses in der welt sein schreibt
immer mit bindestrichen ist auch so ein
neues wort neuer begriff den er mit
blick auf das dasein trägt und in diesem
zitat was ich jetzt zum schluss ihn noch
vorlesen möchte zeigt jetzt heiliger an
dass das dasein in seiner existenz steht
oder auch die da seins analyse die er
auch existenz analyse nennt nicht mit
bereits vorhandenen disziplinen
verwechselt werden darf er sagt die
existenzielle analytik des daseins das
ist die aufgabe von
seinem werk seiner zeit liegt vor jeder
psychologie anthropologie und erst recht
biologie in der abgrenzung gegen diese
möglichen untersuchungen des daseins
kann das thema der analytik noch eine
schärfere umgrenzung erhalten
jetzt kann man sich hier fragen
inwiefern ist die existenz analytik des
daseins vorgelagert der psychologie der
anthropologie und der biologie gut ich
meine der biologie das kann man sich
leicht denken heiliger möchte jetzt hier
nicht eine klassifikation natürliche
arten geben was ja auch die biologie tut
als er möchte jetzt nicht sagen dass das
heim ist eine art zum beispiel homo
sapiens das möchte nicht machen so eine
klassifikation wäre für ihn wieder schon
viel zu sehr an dem vorhandenen
orientiert wir sind der kategorien lehre
anthropologie geht so ein bisschen die
ähnliche richtung der mensch das ist
natürlich auch ein natürliches wesen
natürlich auch ein kulturelles wesen
aber das will heiliger damit nicht sagen
dass sein sohn ihm geht es nicht um
anthropologische bestimmungen zb jetzt
das an die menschen kultur schaffen dass
sie politisch sich betätigen gegensatz
zu anderen natürlichen arten zu nehmen
geht es daran dass bestimmte stimmungen
will sie auch nicht dass die für unsere
existenz entscheidend sind
jetzt kann man sagen gut stimmungen oder
angst oder sorge solche phänomene kennt
natürlich auch die psychologie warum
jetzt nicht psychologie heute gesagt
naja die psychologie fast sorge angst
nur als eigenschaften oder meinen wegen
krankheiten oder defizite des menschen
auf als er hat eine gewisse
anthropologische dimension während die
existenz analyse die theorie die
haltiger vertreten möchte davon ausgeht
dass das dasein wesentlich in seiner
sorge in seiner angst besteht also dass
es sich darin gerade zeigt
also angst und sorge werden bei heiliger
noch viel tiefer gefasst noch viel
existenzialistische kann man sagen oder
auch unter logische also sie werden für
die existenz des daseins als grundlegend
betrachtet während die psychologie ihr
solche dinge als etwas äußerliches
ansieht was nicht die ganze existenz des
jeweiligen subjekts des menschen
ausmacht und das ist so der unterschied
und deswegen sagt auch heilige dass die
da sind analytik vor der psychologie zum
beispiel liegt